connaissez-vous le privilège des
bouilleurs de cru un avantage en voie de
disparition crée à la fin du 19e siècle
à cette époque napoléon autorise les
propriétaires récoltants à fabriquer
leurs propres eaux de vie et leur offre
ce privilège une exonération de taxe sur
les 1000 premiers degrés d'alcool pur
qu'il produit quand quelqu'un vient
quand on a du monde qui vient de la
ville entre c'est la seule chose que
nous pouvons offrir un petit chenapan la
transmission du privilège de bouilleurs
de cru est héréditaire jusqu'en 1960
après le législateur l'interdît seul le
conjoint survivant peut en user jusqu'à
sa propre demande
l'objectif éradiquer le fléau de
l'alcoolisme dans les campagnes un
argument qui ne tenait pas debout selon
le président alsacien du syndicat des
bouilleurs de cru en 1973 non je crois
qu'il s'agit là d'une lutte plus ou
moins ouvertes entre les bouillottes lui
et la distillation artisanale et
industrielle
une lutte qui fragilisait le privilège
napoléonien en 1983 ce bouilleur de cru
en faisait le triste constat les
bouilles or non il y aura pu
disparaissent les uns derrière les
autres
que fera t-on des fruits qui vous
restent bas comme ceux qui portent pas
brûlé par l'ema la poubelle une
raréfaction qui met aussi à mal une
autre profession celle de distillateurs
car tous les bouilleurs de cru ne sont
pas forcément équipés d'un alambic les
distillateur ambulant viennent alors à
eux en automne pour transformer leurs
fruits en alcool
c'était le cas de cet homme dans le
maine et loire en 1983 avec sa machine
qu'il promène de
saint-martin-du-fouilloux à bouchemaine
joseph d'avesnelles soixante trois ans à
pâques transporte un cahier de
déclarations chaque distillation chaque
propriétaire est inscrit à la minute
près à 18h le règlement fiscal l'exigent
la cub doit être entièrement vide sinon
celle amende ou la saisie du matériel
en 2008 c'est
d'autres distillateur évoqué avec
nostalgie la disparition de cette
tradition populaire
l'alambic dans un village c'est écoute
une tradition c'était tout un art de
vivre les gens viennent l'alambic bon
casse la croûte
on fait cuire des saucisses un alambic
bon groupe le ratafia du pays où les
gens viennent même s'ils n'ont pas
décidé ils viennent en discutons oui
c'est vrai c'est une culture c'était une
tradition c'était vraiment quelque chose
de beau dans la campagne
si les bouilleurs de cru privilégiés
sont de plus en plus rares en france
environ cent mille personnes sont encore
habilité à produire leurs propres eaux
de vie selon la fédération nationale du
secteur
ils sont alors taxés à 50% sur les 1000
premiers litres d'alcool produit est
ensuite à 100%
[Musique]